after losing his teenage son to a
reckless driver a Henderson man has
taken his fight to the state capitol
lawmakers held a hearing today for Rex's
law a proposed Bill seeking to impose
partial penalties for those driving
recklessly Joshua paguerra Joins us live
in The Newsroom with more
Brian Kirsten Jason Padgett is turning
his paint into action this year the Man
convicted of killing his son was
sentenced to six years in prison a
sentence patches says was unjust
sentence of one to six years in prison
does not provide adequate Justice for
such an egregious case of reckless
driving
simply put the punishment does not match
the crime SB 322 also called Rex's law
would increase the penalty for driving
incidents that result in serious injury
or death it's currently one to six years
this bill is seeking to increase it to 1
to 10 years sentencing would also
increase 8 to 20 years if the driver is
going over 50 miles per hour I know that
Senate Bill 322 is not going to bring my
son back nor will it increase the
penalty
for the reckless driver who killed my
son lawmakers say there needs to be
consequences for bad behavior and the
current law falls short of that the
state data on traffic fatalities goes
back only to 1991 and in 2022 we saw one
of the highest traffic death counts in
the past 32 years Rex Padgett was killed
in March of last year in front of Manion
middle school walking home from a
friend's house investigators say Jose
hit Rex while driving nearly 100 miles
per hour it took several days before
marmolejo was arrested during his
sentencing in January monomalejo
apologized for his actions I'd like to
give my deepest sorrows
this bill is about standing up for the
countless victims of reckless driving
and providing adequate adequate Justice
for them
is about helping the next family that
will unfortunately find themselves in
our shoes
now a lawmaker proposed amending Rex's
lawsuit just a penalty of a one to ten
year prison sentence If a driver goes
over 50 miles per hour in the offense
happens it remains to be seen Brian
whether it gets adopted